i'm using joycon and i'm ready to go
this is not true dude fake news
meeting bobcats has tv ready
[Music]
to motion controls oh my god
i see what you mean about the map
flickering yeah it's great isn't it
it's the power of the nintendo switch
[Laughter]
and then yep okay yep i'm gonna try to
do it with gyro it's gonna be great
no no one worry about it oh my god
okay i got a helmet nice i'm
gonna say if i were another train
spectating us i would think oh those are
bots they're they're not
just no way can you andy if you look at
me can you see it
like does it look like i'm just moving
with my hands
does it look like dancing
excellent it looks so weird oh man
okay oh i see okay hang on i'm gonna try
and push him
i gotta get my shield back oh maybe i
should go get andy
if you can get andy yeah just just like
tap them up do you wanna come
uh run walk brother crawl over here do
you see me
i'm trying to like flank around because
it doesn't look like you're heading
towards me if i'm being honest
i'm running i'm moving backwards i see
your little thing gotcha yep
come here i'm right next to you eddie
right here right here bud
we got this oh it's so it's so close
just achieving uh
like i feel like i was just playing 40
chess to try to accomplish that and we
did it oh my god ray thank you
oh oh oh this guy's right here yeah
oh yeah i think i'm getting oh no that's
you guys gotta hate this game
oh boy oh i just got shot by maybe
okay gyro okay gyro
oh my god oh yep yep yep i'm doing this
entirely with motion controls no okay he
ran out of
i'm trying to peek out oh yes it's so
hard to see oh yeah
he's he just jumped down he went to us
oh yeah zip line square
don't see a zip line up here oh yeah
you oh is that yours yeah okay
there's a whole there's a whole team in
here oh i just got drilled
right over there where he just backed
off that
platform all right i'm just gonna pick
you up yeah just just just pick me up
and then
leave me
oh andy oh andy
okay okay we got one knot all right and
then i'm down but but ray's back up
yeah but i can't i think i just got
myself no grenade no maybe not
oh no oh
it's all right it's all right why does
he put a menu sweaty looks so bad
what is going on it's insane
should we just drop in hot yeah yeah
all right that's what i've been uh
that's what i've been doing to try and
get better just drop in and force myself
to get into combat situations
we're thinking that things that you
don't have to be as precise with is a
good idea
that's what i'm sticking with and
because of that i have a p20
oh hell yeah the g7 scout's probably a
good call i think i need to throw my
usual loadout just right in the trash i
definitely wish i had a smaller monitor
right now i'll say that
i wish i had like a a 12-inch monitor
why don't you just play from the switch
i wish i had a uh oh my god portable
i'll just see yeah everybody
it does make me feel like i'm blind um i
keep being like what's wrong with my
eyes
i don't know what's happening that's a
great way to sell your game hey do you
like visions
oh we have uh some hemlocks here
oh nice because i could use a little
little optic
i do really want it but then you know
why you know
yeah why put yourself through that like
yeah i think that it would just like i
feel like i'd be cucking myself
if i were to pick up a hemlock right now
and not be able to use it correctly is
exactly the same as watching someone
have sex with my wife
you know you know oh yeah yeah andy i
saw what you're talking about they were
down there
that gibraltar might still be alive that
we were fighting i didn't
properly kill him okay hang on oh
hold on oh uh yeah you see him down
there
i scared him gun wrong gun run gun uh
he's like down there
one of them's down let's push we can we
can do this
oh boy can we this is the kind of
advantages that we need
i oh [ __ ] gyro bro
where are they okay uh i got the wraith
down
okay all right take care i just want to
go oh there you go okay
wait you guys being shot at no no we're
just we're just getting bounced around
oh me too oh boy oh look at the video
controller i can't pick up his
[Applause]
the gravity moves sideways in this area
of king's canyon now
why is this keep taking that back with
every step i take forward
come on you can do it buddy you can do
it oh you'll get up this waterfall
look at the water textures every time i
get close to the crate it moves me
backwards
the water doesn't even move i'm
it feels like it's stop motion animation
uh someone's coming something's coming i
think
no hold on hold on again i think i
should oh yeah
right here
because the gyro like doesn't keep up
with itself
i'm playing with my hands like across my
chest like i'm about to just
get him hit this one guy please i can't
we did so much he's right here don't let
him heal
you got this dude
[Music]
oh no oh no i don't feel ready
oh yes i can't hear you just yet
hold
you guys is this gonna happen there's no
oh behind me by me bye
oh my god
i have a dome holy [ __ ]
i am in i never would have thought that
would happen i'm in absolute disbelief
there was one person near a rock with
like no shield no health and i just kind
of like
kept tapping it and i could tell i don't
think they're playing
on a real console like i don't think
they're playing i think they're playing
on switch because they were
so slow to well that's what i was
thinking that maybe though that that
loss group were also
on twitch but i don't want to do that to
us you know like what if we just don't
think about it that way
no we deserve it we deserve the win
oh this is like this looks like
fallout 2 this is the texture's in here
yeah it pushed us way up this uh this
looks atrocious
god the wag is atrocious he's so low
he's unhealthy
got him there beautiful his teammates
right there right there oh i'm lagging
i am wagging hard okay that's not right
oh i can't do this
i got one of them
it's funny ray that it does specifically
look like you look terrible but anyway
oh
oh my god
um there were too many we got
overwhelmed out here really i see what
you mean there's another team there
yeah it was not a good time
we're gonna be fine it's okay hey we got
that dub we just we just wanted to have
like a fun cheeky game where we just
kind of throw it away you know make
everyone else everything up
everything this is all recreational you
know this is all good
if we did it yeah we did the hard part
already
we're also almost at two thousand
dollars thank you everyone that's
amazing
oh there's people here absolutely
you sure [ __ ] did mate i'm like cool
well i got this ark star
oh yeah i think they're below cindy did
you take two guns
and leave me with none you piece of [ __ ]
here codes
we'll figure it out we'll figure it
[Laughter]
you guys we chat we are at a big
disadvantage they said
seems like you'd be at a huge
disadvantage probably just really bad pc
players what's making you think that
they're bad
we're not doing well we're just
avoiding everyone for a long time yeah
it's not like what what success do you
think that we're having
it's like yeah we're in the ring
water should not look like this i made
some sound i i
the sound i just made oh boy
sorry
it's a series of stripes with oil on top
of it
oh there's still some there they're kind
of they're they're [ __ ] off they're
[ __ ] off they're
oh no they dropped down that's
suspicious what are they doing
i don't know i mean they have to see us
i feel like
maybe they're playing out so let's do a
handheld
god they're going to see the whole thing
okay the zip lining up the hill and then
go this way
all of them yeah they're just going up
the hill maybe they know we have to go
up there because that's where the ring
is
yeah i think we're separate enough that
we might be okay
i'm
i think it's like clay it they're not
everything
looks like uh an instagram filter i
think they're just telling me to throw
my
underneath their ledge i kind of feel
like we should stay out of it until then
yeah i mean we are in the ring
then we just [ __ ] leave them to it no
way they see us you know
except that i kept jumping instead of
crouching by accident
hey what if you saw us though
oh they think they're fighting that's
good
but i don't have eyes on both yeah me
neither all i see is uh
trees from the ps2 era yep pokemon ass
trees
oh jesus oh my [ __ ] oh you're right he
writes that
damn ray where'd he go where'd he go i'm
right next to him
drop that [ __ ]
don't freak out yeah i accidentally
jumped again i promise i just pressed
the wrong button again
it was not intentional they might rush
us we're so [ __ ] if they do
i actually don't think we are if they
rush us and the three of us are behind
one shot
oh god
i don't know that this is the right oh
nice
over here all right
so there might only be two they're
pushing right here
oh that was right behind us this guy has
a white shield
see
oh my god
oh my god it's so difficult